president trump deploys the feds to
quash violence in america's major cities
as democrats protest
joe biden says trump is the first racist
president ever
and left his child parents for wanting
to educate their kids during a pandemic
i'm ben shapiro this is the bench bureau
show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn protect your online privacy
today at expressvpn.com
ben well there are two kind of
different narratives that are emerging
in the united states and i'm not talking
about just ideological narratives
emerging in the united states
i mean two actual views of the fact one
happens to be factual
the other is the view that you are
getting from the media and i say this
advisably because
i'm not one of those people who goes
around saying the media are the enemy of
the people i don't like that sort of
phraseology
but i have never seen the media gaslight
quite as hard as they have for the past
four months in this country it's it's
just it's beyond insane now the media
has al
always driven perverse narratives on the
basis of no fact and they do this on a
fair
on a fairly regular basis but they still
have some tenuous grasp of reality
it is rare to see the fact so blatantly
scaring you in the face
and the media telling you that what you
are seeing is not real the media telling
you
who are you going to believe us or your
own eyes over the past several months we
have heard from the media that andrew
cuomo is an incredible governor of new
york as tens of thousands of people died
we have heard from the media that
violent looting and rioting was not
happening
that these were quote unquote mostly
peaceful protests and that the
protesters and the writers and looters
were completely separate but
if you say rioting and looting are bad
you're actually attacking the protesters
we have heard the media claim
that things are fantastic in seattle's
chop chaz
we heard that it was paradisical it was
wonderful out there
how dare you try to shut down this
street fair
we have heard that enormous protest
of literally millions of people in the
streets in the middle of a pandemic
was not a public health threat directly
after hearing that anti-lockdown
protests were a public health threat
i mean i've truly never seen anything
like it the media over the past several
months and
again they've botched stories before
they've sort of done this on an
individual level they did it with
kavanaugh for example
they did it with the covington catholic
kids but the extraordinary extent
which nearly every story that is being
reported right now
is not in any way reflective of the
underlying facts it's
purely it's pure insanity the most
obvious example of this is what is
happening in portland right now
so in portland things are really bad
they are now in day 56
of rolling rioting okay and rioting is
what is happening in portland
okay it is not a peaceful place it is
not a wonderful place
you can look at the footage can you look
at the portland unrest footage
is clip five and you can see what
exactly is going on important people are
firing fireworks
tear gas has been deployed protesters
are
are breaking down barriers they're
approaching the cops wearing
bicycle helmets and and tear gas masks
and they're using umbrellas and and wood
barriers to shield themselves from
from the cops so that people can't see
them they're vandalizing the federal
courthouse
okay does this look like a peaceful
protest to you this looks like a riot
because that's what it is it is a riot
and just because you have some in
the back of the crowd holding up a group
of balloons
does not mean that this is happy to
happy due time
and if you could see the footage what
you would see is graffiti all over the
place
you can see that the federal building
has been completely
defaced and people have been injured in
portland as well
okay overnight portland rioters set fire
to the courthouse
as well that was another thing that they
did there's footage of them doing so
the portland rioters the police
yesterday right the police were run by
mayor ted wheeler
over there the police there's footage of
them warning
the crowd that they're going to have to
use tear gas if they don't disperse
and this is being portrayed as like a
big nothing
this is all nuts okay this is purely
purely nuts
it's so bad that you end up with these
two minutes hate struggle session so
i will say this is part of this i enjoy
is the politicians
who are allowing this stuff to go on
then being torn up by the protesters i
really
am enjoying this so this happened in
seattle where mayor jenny durkin
basically allowed chop chaz to go on for
weeks at a time
and people were getting shot there and
she's like it's no big deal it's a
street fair guys and then they went to
her house and then she like shut this
thing down
right now it was pretty great when the
mayor of minneapolis
who had allowed half his city to be
burned down went
and did penance in front of protesters
and was screamed at
for not being warm enough towards
defunding the police and so they had
like a full-on struggle session like
they were gonna hang a sign around
his neck and the whole thing over in the
center of minneapolis so that was fun
well yesterday mayor ted wheeler decided
that he was up for his two minutes hate
on oregon public broadcasting
so the mayor shows up in downtown
portland
with the pri protesters and the rioters
and he proceeds to be called a fascist
which is just spectacular stuff it truly
is it is great stuff
more of this please it turns out two
minutes hate is eminently watchable
here's mayor ted wheeler being ripped up
and down by the protesters he is
allowing to terrify and terrorize his
[Music]
[Applause]
city
[Music]
they're calling ted wheeler a fascist
i'm pretty sure that
shutting down the entire city of
portland because
you just feel like burning crap because
you're a terrible person that's a little
more fascist than ted wheeler allowing
you to do it although
he is actually i mean he's an enabler
here right he's the vichy france here i
mean this is
it's pretty incredible but ted wheeler's
the bad guy remember the revolution
always hits its own first that's the way
this works
revolutions rarely take on the strongest
folks instead
they really like taking on the weakest
and ted wheeler is the weakest
the mayor of minneapolis was the weakest
jenny durkin was the weakest
okay so all this stuff is going on right
the burning down portions of portland
and they are screaming at the mayor that
he's a fascist while he forces the
police
to stand there and do nothing and then
we're being told by the media that
literally nothing is happening
everything is good there this is all
peaceful and wonderful
nothing bad is happening a
congressperson from portland his name is
ed blumenauer
he actually testified in the well of the
house yesterday
this bizarro world looking dude this guy
earl blumenauer
who looks like as one of my producers
said yesterday a refugee from a pee-wee
herman outtake
he's standing there with his with his
large purple polka-dotted bow tie
and a lapel pin of a green bicycle i kid
you not like some people wear lapel pins
of the american flag because they pledge
allegiance to the american flag
earl blumenauer pledges allegiance to a
bicycle
he looks like bill nye the science guy
on a bad acid trip
anyway earl blumenauer announced
announced yesterday there is no chaos in
portland
poof it's gone it never really happened
this is gaslighting okay
we've seen the footage i just showed you
the footage here's a everything's fine
guys
why are you making a big deal out of
this just because they're trying to burn
down the courthouse
whatever that's just portland's a kooky
place man
all we do there is we play hippie guitar
and we have vinyl records and we burn
things i mean come on it's portland
portland oregon is not out of control
to be sure there are some people who
have strong feelings and
there are some who have done things that
are inappropriate
and unlawful but that is the challenge
of our local
officials and our state officials to
manage it
not having somebody unwelcome
uninvited and unprepared coming in
to take this difficult situation and
make it worse
it's it's all fake guys and you know how
it's fake you know it's fake because
trump's bad
right this is the basic narrative being
driven by the democrats and by the left
don't believe your lying eyes believe us
and the reason that you should believe
us
is because trump is bad seriously that's
the entire case
you shouldn't believe the evidence in
front of you you shouldn't believe the
footage you shouldn't believe the pure
obvious facts that are right in front of
your eyes because many of the people
showing you those facts don't think
trump is the worst person in the world
and we do think trump is the worst
person in the world so if you believe
trump is the worst person in the world
you will believe us when we say that the
protesters and looters and rioters in
portland are entirely peaceful
and the media mimic this crap they mimic
it up and down
it's truly amazing it's truly amazing
we'll get some more of this in just one
second first
let us talk about the fact that you
don't really want to be going to an auto
parts store right now in fact
you don't really want to go to an auto
parts store ever because the fact is
that you wait in line then finally you
get up to the front and they're asking
you very specific questions about your
card that you may not know off the top
of your head and then they sell you a
generic
part that may not be right for your car
or they have to wait it and
they have to order it and then wait for
it to come in from the from the
manufacturer
why don't you just go and do it direct
with rockauto.com rockauto.com always
offers the lowest prices possible rather
than changing prices based on what the
market will bear like airlines do
why would you spend up to twice as much
for the same part like for example let's
say that you were one of the people who
happened to need a delphi fg 1456 fuel
pump assembly
for a 2005 to 2010 honda odyssey well at
the store that's going to cost you like
354 bucks
at rock auto that's 217 bucks
rockauto.com it's a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years go to rockauto.com right now
shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers best of all
prices at rockauto.com always reliably
low and the same for professionals and
do-it-yourselfers
you don't want to spend too much money
instead why not save money and go to a
great business rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck
red shapiro in there how did you hear
about usbox so they know that we sent
you that's rockauto.com go check them
out
right now and write shapiro in there how
did you hear about us boxes so they know
that we say
the media are just repeating this sort
of propaganda rolling stone which of
course
is a far-left magazine masquerading as a
remember when rolling stone used to do
music
wasn't that funny yeah they don't do
that anymore well now tim dickinson has
a piece called
from the administration that brought you
kids in cages it's tear-gassed moms
that's what they are
they're all just mothers they're just
mothers they're kind
wonderful mothers and we know their
mothers because they say so
and here's how rolling stone reports
what's happening in portland you ready
as nightly protests have dominated
downtown portland for nearly two months
both local officials and the trump
administration have attempted to cast
the largely peaceful demonstrators
as ruffians with suspect political
values hell-bent on destruction
well first of all this phrase largely
peaceful
mostly peaceful as i've said before this
is just the most glorious phrase ever
it's just fantastic because most of
human history like by days counted
most of human history has been peaceful
sure there have been you know these
periods where
hundreds of millions of people die but
aside from that it's mostly peaceful
like johnny depp and amber heard their
marriage it seems mostly peaceful like
for most hours of the day she wasn't
crapping in his bed and he wasn't
tossing bottles at her
i mean there were the occasions where
she was crapping in his bed and he was
tossing bottles at her
but you know like as a percentage of
actual time
it wasn't like 75 of the time it was
like 10
of the time it was a mostly successful
mostly peaceful marriage
mostly peaceful protesters again this is
language that would never
ever ever be used if they disagreed with
the message of the protesters
when it was the tea party they claimed
that the tea party were a bunch of
racist terrorists they could not come up
with any evidence of racism at a tea
party protest
or violence at a tea party protest the
tea partiers were picking up their own
garbage and throwing it in the garbage
can
and they're like these guys are out of
control they're out of control
example today dave weigel of the
washington post
so weigel he put out a tweet saying it
was like 10 minutes ago that open carry
protesters without mass
rallied at state capitals and mostly
democratic governors just let them do it
until they went away
he said this in response to somebody
saying why the hell are democratic
politicians allowing these riots to go
on
yes because open carry protesters
without masks are not the same as people
trying to burn
down the courthouse i mean
can anyone provide evidence of the open
carry protesters trying to occupy entire
swaths of cities
and bar the police and vandalizing
entire downtown areas because i'm old
enough to remember when we shut down the
entire damned county of los angeles for
a week on end
at 6 00 p.m so riders and looters could
run roughshod through melrose boulevard
i'm old enough to remember that because
i am more than four weeks old
my baby is old enough to remember it and
she was born at the beginning of march
hey this is it if you feel like you're
going crazy right now you're not the
media have gone crazy you are the only
sane one you are the only sane one
this is nuts okay but it's not relegated
only to the coverage of portland
bill de blasio is out there claiming
that the spiking murder rates are not
his fault in his city
right it's all just everything's fine
guys he painted something on the street
guys he
painted black lives matter in giant
yellow letters on the street
problem solved what's to blame for the
spiky murder rates it's not bill de
blasio crapping all over the police each
and every day it's not bill de blasio
defunding entire
new classes of cadets which is what
happened in new york city is not bill de
blasio getting rid of the plane closed
unit
it's not bill de blasio basically
encouraging cops to leave the force
bill de blasio says covid is is to blame
for the spiking murder rates it's kovid
which is weird because the
murder rates were not spiking at the
beginning of covet like at all
the murder rates started to spike as
soon as he started giving leeway to the
rioters and the looters and cutting the
cops
that's when the murder rates started to
spike here is giant weirdo groundhog
murderer frankenstein's monster bill de
blasio
talking about how all this murder stuff
you know you're worried about getting
rid of the cops that's in your
imagination
it's covid that is the problem it's
coveted that's the problem
we've had a very tough few months no
doubt and it is directly related to the
coronavirus the dislocation it's caused
in our society the fact that our court
system is not functioning yet
so many factors that have been
absolutely aberrant for just the last
four or five months
but we will beat it back because we've
done that for a quarter century in this
city and joe the key point is
we will do it we the people of new york
city we need the people's involvement to
make the city safer
the nypd and if we ever need any
assistance
that's what localities do when they feel
they need assistance
then wait for that request from locality
that knows what's right for its people
okay so again you are just you're
hearing from people who are attempting
to lie to you
and gaslight you okay so violence has
increased in in
cities around the united states and so
president trump finally said enough is
enough
and he deployed the dhs department of
homeland security to
protect federal property okay there is
statutory authority for the president to
deploy force
to portland to protect federal property
furthermore there are federal laws on
the books federal agents exist in every
major city in the united states they're
there largely
to enforce laws that have been passed
and that are on the books about gang
violence
right not every crime that happens is in
fact a federal crime or if somebody
murders somebody in a city that's not a
federal crime
it's a state crime the feds don't really
have jurisdiction there where the feds
do have jurisdiction is there a lot of
laws on the books
that talk about gang activity
specifically the feds very often
help local law enforcement investigating
gang activity
that involves for example criminal
conspiracy violations
and that that is where the feds come in
and there are federal investigators on
the ground in fact you've seen them in
virtually every
tv show every tv show there's some sort
of murder and suddenly the feds are
there
right the feds have been in cities for a
very long time but apparently president
trump
staffing up in these areas to try and
lower the murder rate in these areas
where the mayors refuse to actually do
anything to protect their own citizenry
it's very very very bad we're going to
get to president trump
finally implementing some level of law
and order and democrats taking the other
side
which in a normal time would be just
political death for them
but they are counting on american hatred
of trump so strongly they are counting
on the media hatred of trump so strongly
that they are hoping that you will
ignore the evidence
of major cities collapsing right in
front of your eyes and be angry at trump
for trying to fix the problem we're
gonna get to that in just one second
first
let's talk about the fact that if you've
got big credit card bills and they're
racking up month on month
that's not a great way to live you gotta
find a responsible way to bring those
bills down and get yourself in financial
control again this is why you might want
to consider a fixed rate credit card
consolidation loan from light stream you
could save thousands of dollars in
interest
rates started 5.95 apr with autopay and
excellent credit
they've got lower than average credit
card interest rates of over 19
apr can get a loan from 5 000 bucks to
100 000 bucks there are absolutely
no fees the application is 100 online
you can even get your money in your bank
account as soon as the day you apply
lightstream believes that people with
good credit deserve a better loan
experience that's exactly what they
deliver one customer said this i heard
about lightstream while listening to one
of my favorite podcasts
it prompted me to do some more research
after shopping around for a personal
loan that would help me get a lower
interest rate there was no one easier to
work with plus
lightstream had the best rate by far
better yet no fees i had my cash within
two business days
overall amazing experience highly
recommended
we got credit card debt and it's racking
up at that 19 apr
then you are really behind the eight
ball get out from behind the eight ball
right now
my listeners can apply today for a
special interest rate discount and save
even more the only way to get the
discount go to lightstream.com
shapiro that's l-i-g-h-t-s-t-r-e-a-m.com
shapiro subject to credit approval rate
includes 0.50 percent
autopay discount terms and conditions
apply offers are subject to change
without notice visit lightstream.com
shapiro for more information and get
your credit card debt
under control okay so president trump is
finally stepping in
he announced yesterday that he'd be
sending the feds to chicago to restore
public safety now again
he is using laws that already exist he's
not passing new laws
he is not moving above and beyond the
law the laws he's been using in portland
are about protecting federal property
under federal law the dhs is emboldened
empowered to protect federal property
and yes they can arrest people who are
not directly next to the federal
property so if they suspect that there
was someone trying to burn down the
courthouse and four blocks away is the
person
they're allowed to go arrest that person
okay then there are federal laws on the
books
with regard to for example cracking down
in gang activity he's been on the books
for a very very long time
trump said listen i'm tired of this i'm
tired of watching our major cities burn
i'm tired of watching 15 people shot
every other day in chicago i'm sending
the feds
today i am announcing that the
department of justice will immediately
surge
federal law enforcement to the city of
chicago
the fbi atf dea
u.s marshals service and homeland
security will together be sending
hundreds of skilled law enforcement
officers to chicago
to help drive down violent crime
and murderers and violent criminals are
breaking a wide range of federal laws
we have that it's as wide as it can be
we will find them arrest them and
prosecute them
they will be in jail for many years to
come that is a good
thing if you're a law abiding citizen of
these cities i do not know why you would
be upset about this
i really don't if you were wildly
exceeding federal authority that'd be
one thing
he is not william barr made this clear
the attorney general he said what we're
talking about
are normal operations to fight crime
right these have long been under federal
purview
to pretend that they are not if you
don't like it change the law but the
executive branch does have the power to
enforce the law
we started using our strong federal laws
that permit us to target those who use
guns
to kill others and those that are
involved in gang activity
our approach was to set up anti-violent
crime task forces in the cities to
enforce
federal law it's important to stress
that the operations we're talking about
are the standard
anti-crime fighting activities we have
been carrying out around the country
for decades and he says we'll be adding
federal agents to already existing
task forces these are street agents and
investigators who will be working to
solve murders and take down
violent gangs he says this is different
than the operations and tactical teams
we use to defend against riots and mob
violence
he's pointing out these are two
different laws that are being invoked he
says we'll continue to confront mob
violence but the operations we're
talking about today
are very different they are classic
crime fighting so the administration has
named this operation
legend not like let's just be a legend
and do it man but
it's named after an actual four-year-old
boy whose name is legend at tallaferra
who was shot and killed while he slept
in kansas city
shortly before july 4th weekend legends
family came
to the actual unveiling of this policy
they were joined by the family of
jacques
vigil a 55 year old grandmother and
daycare worker from albuquerque who was
murdered in her driveway during an
attempted carjacking
he pointed out that they were also
recognizing the tragic murder of a 14
year old named bernardo jones junior in
chicago who's playing basketball in a
park when he was senselessly killed by
gunshots that wounded for
and killed three others he says to carry
out operation legend federal law
enforcement agencies will be committing
additional resources to these cities
including resources from the fbi the dea
the bureau of alcohol tobacco and
firearms
u.s marshals and the department of
homeland security he says today we've
sent over
200 federal agents to kansas city they
unveiled this thing early
earlier this month they're just
ratcheting it up now we are directing a
comparable
amount to augment chicago's existing
violent crimes
initiatives we are providing more than
35 agents to albuquerque
they're also providing financial
assistance to state and local law
enforcement
in these particular areas and they've
made 3.5 million dollars in federal
funding available to the city of chicago
to compensate local law enforcement for
overtime equipment and other expenses
okay so this is not a violation of law
nor is it really an extension of
anything that the federal government has
not done before the media however
are treating this as absolute this is
fascism
trump fascism was trending yesterday on
twitter okay so it's not fascism when
you take over an entire american city
and threaten to burn everything to the
ground
and then scream at your mayor when he
comes to talk to you about stopping it
that's not fascism fascism
is when the federal government uses
existing authority to shut down rioting
looting and murder in its cities
apparently and the media are just
wonderful at this so the media
literally asked trump if the reason he's
doing this is to distract from covert
as though what you're seeing on the
streets is not happening poof it's gone
right the only reason trump would do
this is to distract from covet by the
way which would be the most idiotic
strategy ever is anyone distracted from
covet
who do you know who's distracted from
covet right now here's president trump
answering this question
when you look at chicago and you look at
the job
mayor lightfoot sent me a letter
yesterday and
i think in their own way they want us to
go in there'll be a time when they're
going to want us to go in full blast but
right now we're sending extra people to
help we're arresting a lot of people
that have been
very bad as far as the coronavirus as
you say
i think we've done some amazing things
and i think you'll probably see that
if you compare our statistics to other
countries
the question itself is is idiotic okay
in just a second we're going to get to
the left's response to president trump
sending in
the feds to help local law enforcement
to enforce federal law already
on the books suffice to say they are
perfectly willing to allow people to run
roughshod through their cities so long
as it means owning the cons
now owning the accounts by burning down
your own cities is definitely a take but
that's what we're seeing right now
first i want to talk to you about your
internet freedom so the fact is there
are a lot of people after your data
bigtech they love your data they love to
use that data they love to make money
off that data
also they're hackers out there and they
want your data so they can literally
steal things from you
why would you leave your data out there
instead try express vpn
expressvpn safely anonymizes and masks
your data by using a secure vpn server
when you use expressvpn tech companies
can't see your ip address at all plus
expressvpn also encrypts 100 of your
data
to protect you from hackers and internet
bad guys now i'm always worried about my
internet security so i won't go online
without
activating my expressvpn it doesn't slow
down your internet connection
it is very easy to install it's very
easy to make it run it just runs in the
background
you never think about it's just
protecting you each and every day so why
give tech companies or hackers a free
license to grab your data
it's time to take back your privacy at
expressvpn.com
ben by visiting my special link you get
an extra three months of expressvpn
service for free
who doesn't like to save money right
again that's expr essvpn.com
expressvpn.com to protect
your data today no reason to leave that
data out there unprotected that'd be a
foolish move instead
protect yourself with
expressvpn.comvpn.com
ben okay so the reaction to this is
exactly what you would think
it is it is mayors who are democrats
basically saying i would rather that my
city continue to be a violent hell hole
than allow the feds to actually do what
they are empowered to do under federal
law so bill de blasio giant weirdo
frankenstein's monster
six foot nine groundhog murderer the son
of sam of groundhogs
bill de blasio he actually said i would
sue to stop trump from intervening
in our violent crime problem we must we
must allow the violent crime to continue
this president blusters and bluffs and
says he's going to do things and they
never materialize
on a regular basis so first we should
not overrate his statements they are so
often not true
a second if he tried to do it it would
only create
more problems it would backfire wouldn't
make us safer and we would immediately
take action in court to stop it
from my point of view this would be yet
another example of
illegal and unconstitutional actions by
the president
and we have often had to confront him in
court and we usually win
okay so he is going to sue trump to stop
him from actually implementing the law
meanwhile laurie lightfoot who's an
awful awful mayor of chicago
and who has basically been allowing
shootings to take place in her city
willy-nilly
she said yesterday the real reason that
trump is is doing this is because he's
targeting women
which is a hell of a take he's sending
federal troops and they're not really
troops he's sending federal law
enforcement
to portland which is run by a white man
okay he he's talking about sending
federal law enforcement to places like
kansas city
i'm not aware that the mayor of kansas
city is a woman maybe maybe it is
i'm pretty sure that that is not that
that is not the reason
why the president of the united states
is sending somebody
the mayor of kansas city is a man named
quentin lucas a black man
okay so she says this is really about
trump targeting women so apparently the
fact that she's a garbage mayor and her
city is turning into a hell hole
trump is only sending the feds because
he doesn't like women or some such nons
this is so tiresome it's so tiresome
what do you think people in chicago who
are getting shot at every weekend
have to say about their idiot mayor who
thinks the reason the feds are coming in
is because trump is mean to ladies
the president has been on a campaign now
for some time
against democratic mayors across the
country
whether it's me whether it's keisha
lance bottoms in atlanta
whether it's mural bowser and washington
cc
whether it's jenny durkin in seattle do
you see a common theme here
the president is trying to divert
attention
from his failed leadership on covet
19. okay um
really that's what's going on here and
again i love that she specifically picks
out only the cities where there's female
leadership she ignores the fact that
trump hates
bill de blasio she ignores the fact that
trump really doesn't like ted wheeler
i think there are there are a lot of
people trump doesn't like the ladies but
this is what sort of what a cheap trick
meanwhile jay johnson the former
homeland security secretary
is provocative he's provocative to send
federal agents into cities to you know
protect federal property
provocative yeah we should do exactly
what what judge johnson did when he was
the when he was the
department of homeland security head we
should let ferguson burn to the ground
good good idea jay
a surge like this would probably be
unnecessarily provocative and actually
make matters worse
the militaristic presence on the streets
of the united states in our cities
during moments of high tension can
actually make matters worse and be
provocative there is legislation working
its way through
to limit the sale of defense department
equipment
to civilian law enforcement in our
cities because
it is provocative you see those images
of
people who used to work for me in
camouflage who look
like the military uh and it's
provocative
he keeps saying provocative provocative
the people who are
apparently being provoked were trying to
burn down the courthouse five seconds
ago i feel like they were already
provoked
it's like the dumbass argument that you
constantly hear from folks on the
international left
where you know like the israelis
responding to hamas
bombing pizzerias it's it's provocative
how dare there
i'm pretty sure these folks were already
provoked they're in the streets trying
to burn down the damn courthouse
you know michael chertoff who's the head
of homeland security under under
president bush he said well maybe
they're exceeding their authority he
said it's possible they're exceeding
their authority
well i mean maybe is not the same as
they are
right why don't you explain how they're
exceeding their authority
you can protect federal property but
that doesn't mean it's an
unlimited license to roam around the
streets
and pick up people based on some
suspicion that maybe they're
involved they're going to be involved in
something roving around on the street
and stopping people
and uh taking them down strike me as
going beyond that authority
and that's wholly apart from the fourth
amendment issue
because whatever the statutory thought
no we still have a constitution okay yes
and the fourth amendment has not been
violated here you are allowed to arrest
people for committing felonies in public
places without a warrant
that is a that is a supreme court
established doctrine that is a fact
and by the way here is what the law says
word for word 40 u.s code section 1315
law enforcement authority of secretary
of homeland security for protection of
public property the secretary may
designate employees of the department of
department of homeland security
including employees transferred
to the department of the office of the
federal protective services of the
general services administration pursuant
to the homeland security act of 2002
as officers and agents for duty in
connection with the protection of
property owned or occupied
by the federal government and persons on
the property including
duty in areas outside the property to
the extent necessary to protect the
property
and persons on the property well engaged
in the performance of official duties an
officer or agent designated under the
subsection may
enforce federal laws and regulations for
the protection of persons and property
carry firearms make arrests without a
warrant for any offense against the
united states committed in the presence
of an officer or agent
or for any felony cognizable under the
laws of the united states
if the officer or agent has reasonable
grounds to believe that the person to be
arrested
has committed or is committing a felony
okay i'm reading you the black letter
law
that is the actual law so don't give me
that the agents in portland are
violating the law i just read you the
law
the law says they are doing exactly what
they are supposed to be doing
so this ain't about tyranny it's not
about fascism
it's about don't believe your own eyes
don't believe that the cities are
burning and that president trump is
doing something about it because that
might be a narrative in favor of
president trump this is how you end up
with idiotic articles like this one from
the new york times republicans pounce
pouncies pounds this is what they're
constantly doing over at the new york
times
when democrats do something dumb well
stories never democrats do something
dumb
the story is always the republican
response to the democrats doing
something dumb
so the democrats have decided to let
their cities burn and turn into chaotic
hellholes
and the response of the media is look at
these evil right-wing media folks
talking about it headline from the new
york times
right-wing media stars amplify trump's
law and order campaign message
first of all how in what way is that
news and that that headline is
right-wingers are right-wing i'm
confused how's that news
sub-headline sean hannity rush limbaugh
and other conservative pundits have
seized on the portland protests
as a pro-trump rally and cry so much
pouncing
so much seizing unbelievable right-wing
outlets and conservative media stars
have seized on the weeks-long protests
in portland
as a rallying cry for law and order
instructing their followers to fear for
their safety
and blaming democratic leaders for
failing to restore peace oh man the
gaslighting is so
strong instructing their followers to
fear for their safety let me tell you
something
i don't think you have to tell people to
fear for their safety i think people
fear for their safety when they feel
unsafe
you know what made me feel unsafe in the
city of los angeles when they shut down
the entire damned county for a week to
let marauders
break into the foot locker down the
street that made me feel a little unsafe
i didn't need rush to tell me to feel
unsafe
idiots it's it's just it's incredible
the gas lighting is beyond the pale
beyond the pale
speaking of which you want to talk about
media bias okay best example of media
biases remember that time
when the new york times ousted the
editor of the op-ed page because they
ran
an editorial from tom cotton an op-ed by
tom cotton
they ran a piece of full-blown chinese
propaganda today
in the new york times by a guy who works
for the chinese government
the title of the piece was my relatives
in wuhan survived my uncle in new york
did not because china is better than new
york
okay it's just a full piece of
full-blown propaganda where are the
protests over the new york times
page where are they the new the new
editor of the new york times.page
why isn't that person being called to
account for printing chinese propaganda
this guy's a propagandist on behalf of a
regime that is currently shipping
uyghurs into concentration camps to be
sterilized
and that's okay that's fine according to
members of the
new york times woke staff okay in just a
second we're going to move on to
joe biden and kovet because joe biden
i got to say this this presidential
battle
it's not really a battle of wits i would
say a lot of unarmed people
in this in this battle of wits we're
gonna get to this in just one second
first
summer is the time to get things done
why else would the days be longer i get
it who wants to be taking classes this
time of year
you you because you're tenacious you
want to make your resume better you want
to learn
more things that's why you listen to
informative podcasts like this one
be your best most tenacious self this
summer get to work earning your degree
at ashford
university at ashford university your
classroom goes with you the classes are
built for summer fun you can learn from
your patio the beach
wherever you are you're not going to pay
a fortune to do it you know harvard
right now is charging like 51
000 for streaming classes why in the
world would you do that ashford
university's expert faculty teaches real
world skills
drawing on their years of real-world
experience you can pursue
you can pursue your bachelor's and
master's degree and one of ashford's
60-plus programs like business
administration
healthcare administration and psychology
best of all ashford's programs allow you
to learn on a convenient and flexible
schedule you can take online
in the sun with 24 7 access to your
classroom daily support financial aid
available
ashford will give you the tools you need
to help you achieve your goals
be your best most tenacious self make
your resume better this summer
head on over to ashford university today
there's no fee to apply or standardized
testing required to enroll head on over
to ashford.edu
ben is ashford.edu ben ashford.edu
not all programs available in all states
okay in just a second we're gonna get to
joe biden
who continues his delusional campaign
doesn't mean ain't gonna win
but uh dude is not with us and has not
been with us for some time we'll get to
that
in just one moment first my new book how
to destroy america in three easy steps
it is on sale now it is a huge
bestseller already thanks to people
like you if you haven't bought it yet
you should go buy it right now the book
covers two different visions of america
we are watching them play out in real
time one vision says that america
is an amazing place rooted in a true
philosophy
of the declaration of independence and
the constitution rooted in a culture of
entrepreneurship and tolerance
rooted in a history that attempted to
fulfill the promises of the declaration
and increasingly has done so
the other side says america sucks as it
would be robin d'angelo's white
fragility the new york times 16 19
project the rioters and looters in the
streets
the media who defend them
disintegrationists are using weapons
like cancel culture to go after you
and anybody who agrees with you my book
discusses all of this and is really the
antidote to it how to destroy america in
three easy steps it details how
this disintegrationist worldview has
gained so much cultural ground so
quickly
it offers what i think is a really
important view of the culture at this
point in our history and more
importantly it offers you the ammo to
rebut the dumb arguments that are being
made
on behalf of tearing down the country
you can pick it up on amazon or at
barnes noble
right now also tomorrow friday we'll be
holding one of our
vaunted daily wire backstage is a
socially distanced
backstage come join me and several other
humans at 4 pm pacific to hear us lament
the collapse
of the republic also go get a reader's
pass over at dailywire.com
readers passing grade all sorts of good
stuff so join us become part of the crew
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so meanwhile the presidential
campaign continues a pace
and let us just say that it feels as
though
there is some insufficiency in
representing these particular positions
so you have some
pretty rich ideological strains in
american public life being represented
by the political right right now
a strain of law and order a strain that
says that america was found in liberty
defending american history defending
american culture
and the president when he gives speeches
off teleprompter does a good job of
explicating that right his mount
rushmore speech i thought was terrific
and i said so
the president also has a bad habit of
going off the cuff about weird stuff
that allows the media to focus in on it
so
today today the president did another
interview where he decided to do like a
five-minute riff
on how tough the cognitive test he took
was that he aced
and so he just kept saying over and over
the five words that he was supposed to
memorize
it was not a great clip not not an ideal
clip
so they say could you repeat that so i
said yeah
so it's person woman man camera tv
10 minutes 15 20 minutes later to say
remember the first question not the
first but the 10th question
give us that again can you do that again
and you go person
woman man camera tv
if you get it in order you get extra
points
they said nobody gets it in order it's
actually not that easy but for me it was
easy
meanwhile joe biden continues to be
senile so
as i've said before any presidential
debate here will be chewbacca versus the
swedish chef
from the muppets that's that's what this
will sound like
it'll be just phenomenal say on the one
side you have
captain i passed a cognitive test that
pretty much everybody who's not senile
needs to pass
and on the other side you have joe i
once got a fight with a guy named corn
pop
biden yesterday joe biden suggested that
trump was the first racist president
ever
which okay first of all trump isn't a
racist second of all
if joe biden thinks that trump even if
you thought trump was a racist if you
think he was the first racist president
ever
that's a hell of a that's a hot take
coming out there 100 miles per hour
from joe biden here's your biden coming
out hot as his as his forehead begins to
collapse
into his into his nasal cavity here's
here's joe biden
no sitting president has ever done this
never
never never no republican president has
done this no democratic president
we have racist and they've existed
they've tried to get elected president
he's the first one that has
is he though are we just i've got some
questions
we had like uh of the i mean if we're
going to talk about you know people who
thought that black folks were inferior
every president in the early republic
was in fact a slaveholder with the
exception of john adams and john quincy
adams i believe every single one
up to the end of the andrew jackson
tenure was a slave holder
so that seems like maybe maybe not maybe
trump's not the first rate but
first of all i don't understand how joe
biden could possibly miss the fact that
woodrow wilson was a brutal racist
considering that
when woodrow wilson was a child he
massaged joe biden's leg hair that's how
old joe biden is
like this is just pure crazy from joe
biden but joe biden is pure crazy at
this point so we got
a senile old man hiding in his basement
and then we got president trump the most
volatile candidate in the history of the
american republic
things are going great here guys things
are things are just excellent on every
level
here's the thing here's the thing there
are underlying principles at stake here
and that's what's easy to miss because
presidential politics is so much a game
of personality and so little about the
actual policies represented by the
candidates i talk about this and how to
destroy america in three easy steps a
little bit
i point out that the various views of
president trump
are based on a misunderstanding of how
people see trump
on the right the way that most
conservatives see trump is not as the
godsend beautiful man incredible at
everything
people on the right don't see trump the
way trump sees trump people on the right
largely and i think almost entirely see
trump
as a as a vessel a very very flawed
vessel
for stopping the on rushing power of the
of the radical left
i see trump is a bulwark that's who they
see trump as they see him as a as a
a person holding his finger in the dike
to prevent what is inevitably going to
come if joe biden is elected president
and they're not wrong to see it this way
bernie sanders came out yesterday he
said that biden will be the most
progressive president
since fdr he's bought into our entire
agenda right this is what trump is
trying to tell people
now the problem is that because trump is
not a laser-focused campaigner because
he sort of grabs everything in the in
the pantry and just throws it at people
because the president is the the guy you
wouldn't want to fight in high school he
wasn't exactly
a uh he wasn't exactly a methodical
fighter
but he was a guy who might just randomly
turn around and pick up a desk and hurl
it at you
but because he's like that he's not
methodical enough to make the case that
joe biden is basically
a a weak a weak need character who's
gonna get shoved around by bernie
sanders which is the reality
but bernie knows the score here here's
bernie explaining
that basically biden is going to be
bernie with a biden mask on
the reason i say that i think that biden
has a chance to be the most progressive
president
since fdr is that is exactly what joe
biden said to me
and i think he has said that publicly he
understands
the severity of this moment we have tens
of millions of people
who have lost their jobs lost their
health care people who are hungry
today we have an educational system
which
is lacking for low-income and
working-class kids climate change is out
there
joe understands this is an existential
threat to the planet
now that's the case that trump is going
to have to make is that bernie is
actually the spokesperson for the joe
biden campaign that's going to be easier
once biden picks a vp right now biden
has been able to skate on the fact that
people largely perceive him as
non-threatening but the fact is there
are some larger principles at stake
in this election i think people feel
that inevitably it's just that there are
two
very cracked glasses who are going up
against each other right now
on all of this now there's an easy way
for republicans to blow this thing
before it even begins
and that is the aid that has been put
out there this kind of fire hose that's
been turned on the american public since
we've all been forced into lockdown over
and over and over
that fire hose of aid which in many ways
was good
right it was necessary it was necessary
because as i said that is not a
keynesian stimulus program
when somebody drives an f-150 truck
through the front wall of your home
they owe you a reparation for that right
they owe you
damages for that the federal and state
governments have basically destroyed
every business in the united states or
at least a huge percentage of businesses
in the united states
the very least they can do is at least
fill in the gap for the moment
well the crisis has not abated we are
still seeing most
businesses shut down across the united
states and the businesses that can run
are being forced to run
at half capacity so the idea of
extending aid beyond august 1
makes a lot of sense but republicans are
busy fighting over this thing which
makes
no sense to me it is political
malpractice according to the washington
post
senate republicans struggled to finalize
the 1 trillion coronavirus relief bill
on wednesday confronting internal
divisions and continued white house
demands for a payroll tax cut
most lawmakers oppose now i don't know
why you would oppose the payroll tax cut
i really don't apparently there are a
lot of republicans who are concerned
that people
that the democrats are going to say
they're raiding social security or
something
okay that's insanity no one cares about
that right now
seriously no one cares about that right
now people want to make sure they have
the money to pay the bills for the next
few weeks
at the very very least okay nobody just
pass a bill include the payroll tax cut
most americans will want the money back
in their pocket by the way i'm never
expecting to see my social security
money
i'm 36 years old i'm never going to see
it it's gone okay this the whole thing's
a giant damned ponzi scheme
so give me back my money right now now
there's certain ways in which you can
make this bill better than the old bill
like for example you can in fact try to
peg people's unemployment to what they
were earning
so as not to encourage people to stay
out of the workforce one of the problems
with the with the old bill is that it
basically just threw money at people so
they were earning more money by being
unemployed than by being employed you
don't actually want that you want to
encourage people to be employed where
they can be employed
but the extension of unemployment
insurance to people
in a time when the government is
literally forcing them not to go to work
makes a lot of sense if republicans find
a way to blow that
it's a mistake there are a lot of times
when you when you say listen we can't we
can't spend this way
this is not one of those times it isn't
because again what we are talking about
is the government has created
the problem the government has created
the problem
at a certain point here the government
won't have created the problem most
states will basically said to people go
act
as responsibly as you want to and we can
start to get back to normal that is not
where we are
right now so well i admire senator ted
cruz i'm very i'm very friendly with
senator cruz when cruz
says things like i'm not only a no i'm a
hell no on the idea of really extending
more aid here at least the way we're
doing it there is a certain level of
urgency that outweighs the political
concerns on spending at this very moment
in time
we still don't know the details of this
initial proposal
but as it's written tonight right now
i'm not only a no
i'm a hell no and and sadly i think this
is envisioned as an opening gambit
we everyone expects the democrats to
come back with a huge wish list of
spending
and and this is the swamp in a feeding
frenzy
everybody's lobbyist has their hand out
saying well look if you're spending
trillions of dollars i want to get some
and it's not right okay he's right that
it's not right it's also the only way
that something is going to get done
right now i mean let's just be real
about this
if it's a choice between filling in the
hole in the front wall
and doing it wrong right putting too
much spackle on that wall
and not and just leaving the hole in the
wall republicans don't have
a major choice here now meanwhile on the
covid front president trump again
reiterated yesterday he's been doing
these these covet updates he reiterated
yesterday that we should reopen the
schools the evidence is very good that
we should reopen the schools that
doesn't mean that we can't take
precautions particularly on behalf of
teachers
but what the studies tend to show at
this point is that
kids are not getting this at as high
rate as adults that when kids do get it
they are not endangered
that kids are not transmitting this as
easily to adults that mostly
the way coronavirus is being passed is
by adults to other adults in
air-conditioned closed areas for long
periods of time
and that is mainly how this thing is
being passed there's a reason schools
are open across europe
the evidence that kids are the chief of
vectors or even a major
vector in passing this thing the
evidence is really not there here's
trump yesterday pointing out that kids
don't catch covet as easily which
happens to be factually true the media
of course very upset that he would
mention this
they don't transmit very easily and a
lot of people are saying they don't
transmit and we're looking at that with
studying john very hard
that particular subject that they don't
bring it home with them now they don't
catch it easily they don't bring it home
easily and if they do catch it they get
better fast we're looking at that fact
that is a factor and we're looking at
that very strongly he's exactly right
here he was ripped up and down for this
he's exactly right even political had to
acknowledge he was exactly right quote
kids still appear to be less likely to
catch and transmit the the virus the
leading explanation is that kids make
fewer receptors a protein called ace2
making it more difficult for the virus
to latch on said mark schleich a
pediatric infectious disease expert at
the university of minnesota
medical school as children move into
adolescents and become adults they make
more of these receptors theoretically
increasing their chance of contracting
the virus
there are 317 711 reported covet 19
cases in children and teenagers across
the united states
there have been 77 reported deaths 77
across the country of 330 million people
this this is not a major risk to kids it
is not a major risk to kids not only is
it not
a major risk to kids there are some
fairly good science suggesting it's not
a major risk to adults who come into
contact with kids
mark woolhouse a senate a leading
epidemiologist and member of the
government's sage committee over in
great britain
told the london times it may have been a
mistake to close schools in march given
the limited role children
play in spreading the virus he said that
children in the 5-15 age brackets are
not passing this thing
to teachers he said there has been no
recorded case of
a teacher catching the coronavirus from
a people anywhere in the world anywhere
as of july 21st so what about israel
right that was the big counter example
well it is unclear that the students
passed it to the to the teachers it's
quite possible the teachers passed it to
each other
and then they passed it on to everybody
else
kids are passing it to each other but
that does not mean that kids are a chief
vector of transmission there's a study
from iceland suggesting that kids are
not passing it
to adults according to the uk spectator
a company called decoded genetics did a
study in iceland
the test they tested something like 36
500 people
the tests identified 1801 cases of
people suffering from the disease
and 10 deaths each case was carefully
tracked in not a single
case could the researchers find evidence
of a child passing on the disease
to their parents he suggested the fact
that few children suffer any symptoms
and are less likely to cough
is an important factor we have studies
from australia that suggest exactly the
same thing
that schools are not the chief factors
of transmission and there's an
australian study of how coronavirus
spread in 15 schools they found a
transmission rate of far less than one
percent
naturally the media have then suggested
that if you want to reopen the schools
it's because
you want to murder all of the teachers
which is just pure full-scale insanity
but again
the media have been gaslighting you all
along on so many of these issues that
doesn't mean everything the media say is
not true
because a lot of what the media say is
true covert 19 is more dangerous than
the flu
it is something you should be worried
about is it something you should be
panicked about
are we at the same point that we were
back in march are tens of thousands of
americans
about to die daily are we even gonna get
back to new york rates of death on a
daily level no
cases have already begun to wane in
texas florida and arizona
the number one state for new cases is
california which never stopped the
lockdown
effectively so examine the evidence
before you buy into the media narrative
all right we'll be out here a little bit
later today with two additional hours of
content in the meantime
go pick up a copy of my new book how to
destroy america and through easy steps
also
if you want something entertaining to do
this afternoon aside from listening to
the rest of the show
go give a listen to joe rogan's podcast
i did his podcast with him yesterday i
think that it was fun i think it was
entertaining
be warned it is rated at the very least
pg-13 there is some language
so language and nudity not actual
physical nudity
just discussions of such you can go
check that out over at joe rogan's
podcast i think that you will
enjoy in the meantime pick up my
best-selling book how to destroy america
in three easy steps otherwise we'll see
you here
tomorrow i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
supervising producer mathis glover and
robert sterling assistant director pablo
wydowski
technical producer austin stevens
playback and media operated by nick
sheehan
associate producer katie swinterton
edited by adam syavets
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the american republic is
collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
is turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
[Music]
clayton
you